I see cucumber was for a prostate cancer, right? Yes.
So for your prostate cancer, I have no trouble using that.
Rex, if you, if you have that and want to use that.
We have a CQ cover that I tested when I did your cheek swap test.
It didn't test, but if you have a different product, it may be better.
If you feel like God's leading you by all means do that.
I see there is no downside to do that to using that.
So it isn't.
Well, that's why I just say, you know, I don't know if you're here with that first question answer to us.
Can I use other supplements?
The only thing I say is just ask it.
Ask.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's no downside to that.
There's no negatives to that.
Okay.
I had on the, on the, there's two other programs on the kidney, kidney stones there.
Can you explain that there's one that like a kid kidney stimulus and then there's a kidney.
I remember what the other one was in the right machine.
Are those kind of all the same or not?
There's a little different frequencies, depending on what you're trying to do.
So let's say if the person has low functioning kidney.
So some people have like a 20% function of a kidney, you know.
So then you're running a kidney stimulus program trying to stimulate function of the kidney.
So there's just little different frequencies in there.
So that wouldn't really be, I mean, you could say, well, couldn't that help a kidney stone because it could help you flush it?
Yeah.
You know, so if I had kidney stones that we running all those programs.
Good.
Great.
So it's good.
All right.
Thank you.
Yes.